dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaifer
a computer graphics paper from
approximately three years ago
was able to simulate the motion of these
bubbles
and even these beautiful collision
events between them
in a matter of milliseconds this was
approximately 300 episodes ago
and in this series we always say that
two more papers down the line
and this will be improved significantly
so now
once again here goes another one of
those two minute papers
moments of truth now three years later
let's see how this field evolved let's
fire up this new technique that will now
simulate the evolution of two
cube-shaped droplets for us
in reality mother nature would make sure
that the surface area of these droplets
is minimized
let's see yes droplets form immediately
so the simulation program understands
surface tension
and the collision event is also
simulated beautifully
a plus however this was possible with
previous methods
for instance a paper by the name surface
only liquids could also pull it off
so what's new here well let's look under
the hood
and find out oh yes this is different
you see normally if we do this breakdown
we get
triangle meshes this is typically how
these surfaces
are represented but i don't see any
meshes here
i see particles great but what does this
enable us to do
look here if we break down the
simulation of this beautiful fluid
polygon
we see that there is not only one kind
of particle here there are
three kinds with light blue we see sheet
particles
the yellow ones are filament particles
and if we look inside with dark blue
here
you see volume particles with these
building blocks
and the proposed no simulation method we
can create much more sophisticated
surface tension related phenomena so
let's do
exactly that for instance here you see
soap membranes
stretching due to wind flows they get
separated
lots of topological changes take place
and the algorithm handles it
correctly in an other example this soap
bubble
has been initialized with a hole and you
can see it
cascading through the entire surface
beautiful work and after we finish the
simulation of these fluid chains
we can look under the hood and see how
the algorithm thinks
about this piece of fluid once again
with dark blue
we have the particles that represent the
inner volume of the water chains
there is a thin layer of sheet particles
holding them together
what a clean and beautiful visualization
so how much do we have to wait to get
these results
a bit simulating this fluid chain
example took
roughly 60 seconds per frame this
droplet on a plain example
runs approximately 10 times faster than
that
it only needs six and a half seconds for
each frame
this was one of the cheaper scenes in
the paper and you may be wondering
which one was the most expensive this
water bell
took almost 2 minutes for each frame
and here when you see this breakdown
from the particle color coding
you know exactly what we are looking at
since part of this algorithm runs on
your
processor and a different part on your
graphics card
there is plenty of room for improvements
in terms of the computation time for a
follow-up paper
i cannot wait to see these beautiful
simulations in real time
two more papers down the line what a
time to be alive
i also couldn't resist creating a slow
motion version of some of these videos
if this is something that you wish to
see make sure to click our instagram
page link in the video description for
more
this episode has been supported by
lenode lynode is the world's largest
independent cloud computing provider
linode gives you full backend access to
your server which is your step up to
powerful
fast fully configurable cloud computing
lynode also has
one-click apps that streamline your
ability to deploy websites
personal vpns game servers and more
if you need something as small as a
personal online portfolio
lynode has your back and if you need to
manage tons of clients
websites and reliably serve them to
millions of visitors
linode can do that too what's more they
offer
affordable gpu instances featuring the
quadro rtx
6000 which is tailor-made for ai
scientific computing
and computer graphics projects if only i
had access to a tool like this
while i was working on my last few
papers to receive
twenty dollars in credit on your new
lynnode account visit lino.com
papers or click the link in the video
description
and give it a try today our thanks to
leonard for supporting the series
and helping us make better videos for
you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time